1 virtually every individual who has
made a lasting mark on business on the
economy and politics on culture has
possessed the academics ingrained habit
of thinking critically it is a fact that
the best leaders in any venue have
always considered and are always
considering alternative viewpoints that
is why Columbia College Dean Jim
valentini who you will hear from and the
rest of us who have traveled here from
Morningside Heights are so proud of
Columbia's academic curriculum and of
course especially the core curriculum
great universities must strike the right
balance between the world of ideas and
the world of practical demands we must
be attuned to society's needs and
realities without ever letting
conventional wisdom slow or constrain
the pursuit of scientific breakthroughs
and new knowledge when that balance is
properly struck academic institutions
make their greatest contributions New
York City is also always striving for a
similar balance no city is more solidly
grounded in day-to-day reality than the
city and no city has less patience for
being told that a new and better way of
doing things doesn't exist so for me the
excitement of the Columbia startuplab
that we're here to celebrate and open is
that it is a place where some of our
most talented young people will be
negotiating these trade-offs right
before our eyes in real time with real
consequences when is it time to revise a
master plan when is it time to disregard
people who would be negative about an
idea and then still push forward how
important is the approval or the
criticism of your peers and is the
ultimate goal goal too ambitious or two
models here in this beautiful new
facility 45 teams of recent Columbia
graduates each of them possessing
unlimited potential will be grappling
with these essential challenges they
will be better for it as will Columbia
University as well the city of New York
and society at large for supporting this
endeavor I want to thank the for Dean's
with us today Jim valentini Mary boys
the Dean of Columbia School of
Engineering and Applied Science Glenn
Hubbard Dean of the Columbia Business
School and Merritt jano Dean of the
School of International and public
affairs I especially want to thank
Richard Witten the head of our program
in Columbia entrepreneurship in many
capacities over the years including what
as being one of our most outstanding
trustees richard has supported Columbia
in too many ways to count this project
may suit him better than any of the
others now please welcome new york city
controller scott stringer
well first of all I want to just
congratulate the deans and president
Bollinger for this incredible initiative
it's very clear the Columbia recognizes
that one of the ways that this city
thrives is by leveraging our
universities to grow our economy and
they're getting involved in staying
involved not only in the development of
its students but in the development of
our society and I think that's a
critical link between the aspirations of
our city and the world economy you know
we want our entrepreneurs are young
entrepreneurs to dead or run with their
idea the ones that run in areas that are
less traveled and are willing to take
risk and make a case for an application
that perhaps can change our city and
change the world and what's happening
here today is very extraordinary because
it serves to put everyone in the world
on notice that New York will be second
to none when it comes to innovation and
challenging the next generation I also
think it's very exciting president
Bollinger that you're we work today for
those of you who haven't been here
actually think this is one of several of
the most important facilities in New
York City one of the most important
because in we work shared office space
is a whole bold new way young opera
entrepreneurs are working together
they're sitting around a conference
table with laptops and challenging each
other and trying to start a business and
raise capital and it's happening through
these kind of buildings throughout the
city and there must be more of them that
is going to be our challenges of
government to provide the broadband and
the physical space for all of you
entrepreneurs to do your work you know I
have to admit I grew up sort of in that
mad men era when the when you aspire to
the large corner office and you close
the door and work by yourself and you
didn't get to think out of the box well
now I've have that aspiration I have a
big corner office in the controllers
office and it's very much outdated the
next generation of entrepreneurs are
going to be in facilities like this
thinking and challenging and that's how
we grow our economy and that's why I
just had to be here today to be it we
work to be
columbia to be with all of you
entrepreneurs we're going to change our
society and I just want to congratulate
each and every one of you I wish I could
stay but I just got to get back to my
quarter office today so but but I will
be back to make the case for many more
of these programs with our universities
thank you all very much and
congratulations
thank you so much Scott it's it's now my
pleasure to introduce Glenn Hubbard Dean
of Columbia Business School and the
Russell Carson professor of finance and
economics thank you Richard this is an
incredible event for those of you did
not have the chance yet to see this
space I strongly urge you just have a
few quick thank yous and thoughts thank
you especially the tu Lee and to you
Richard for your leadership means a lot
for this and the work at our own
entrepreneurship Center but importantly
at the business school we've had a
Dean's Advisory Board of students that
suggested an idea like this to me some
years ago this is our second version
around of this activity and this is
really really terrific I teach
entrepreneurship that's what I do at the
school although I'm an economist and I
do it because I think it's the core of
what we do I always remind students that
I have only three aspirations for them
one is that they learn to identify an
opportunity the second is that they
learn to connect dots that are hard to
connect and the third is they did that
they develop themselves as leaders I'm
about to see something really radical to
you I know it may not look like a
radical today but but to say something
radical those are all teachable and they
all equal the word entrepreneurship
which is why this is so front and center
to us you know universities are an
ecosystem for this entrepreneurship is
not something that happens off campus it
happens on campus really interesting
ideas in engineering in medicine in
computer science and journalism they all
for us have a business element that's
why I'm so excited for my own school the
student interest at the business school
in entrepreneurship is off the charts
part of that is about the tech boom in
the nation but part of it is about
interest in any complimentary business
whether it's in life sciences or
reimagining the financial services
business for the economy as a whole this
is good stuff my economics colleague Ned
Phelps has a masterful book on mass
flourishing pointing to the centrality
of entrepreneurs
in the economy that's what this is all
about so congrats to everybody on an
activity this good I think there'll be
more of it it's exciting for Columbia
Business School of the University it's
now my pleasure to introduce my
colleague the engineering Dean a merry
voice
so it's really such a pleasure to be
here I want to say a few words about
Columbia engineering that right now
engineering is really in a renaissance
period that we have so much direct
impact on engineering and transforming
society and having impact on our
everyday lives and on and on our future
entrepreneurship is a vital component to
really translating our ability to have
new developments new research into real
impact so in educating and preparing our
future leaders Columbia is now really
committed to providing this support for
entrepreneurship and for innovation
across the entire university so as a few
other examples including to the
incredible start of blood pier today
we're really fostering the fact that
Columbia students are really thinkers
and doers that we have a an ability to
really not only come up with new ideas
but to transform them into real action
and real products so we launched a
makerspace we've launched ignition
grants we have an entrepreneurship minor
we have entrepreneurship evenings or
really celebrate the entire
entrepreneurial community of our
students our alums our faculty so these
events and these activities really
foster innovation and entrepreneurship
across the entire university so today
with the startup lab this is really such
a great part for engineering to be part
of this
together with our our peers from the
business school from the college from
International and public affairs so we
anticipate that this interdisciplinary
environment of the lab will foster even
further innovation beyond even just the
nucleation companies that are here today
I want to give a couple of examples
because i know people won't get around
to all of them so i'm going to give
three quick brief examples neuro spell
was founded by Jason sherlyn and Jordan
were askin they're from biomedical
engineering this startup was recently
profiled in Scientific American it's
developed and applied brain computer
interface to track perception during
rapid decision making for applications
in law enforcement the military
navigation driving and even sports where
knowledge about response time and
decision making is critical pyrus was
founded by michael boyd to check and
daniel Heyman's these were from columbia
engineering and columbia college and
this venture is developing an
application that automatically
translates real life interactions into
memorable leads Pirates will allow users
to take networking to a whole new level
words I was founded by Bob coin and
Daniel barb from computer science words
I is a technology and social media tool
that allows users to create
three-dimensional scenes from simple
natural language descriptions so through
the startup loud these ventures are
going to really have an ability to take
off in two directions that we don't even
know yet and so it's really just such a
pleasure to be here to see all these
different different companies nucleating
and you know I do invite everyone to
make sure you go around and see what
everyone's doing
today so thank you again and
congratulations to all our adventures
and now I'd like to hand it over to my
friend and colleague James valentini the
Dean of the College
thank you Mary Joseph Schumpeter the
great Austrian American economists
defined an entrepreneur as someone
willing and able to convert a new idea
or invention into a successful
innovation Columbia entrepreneurship
aims to facilitate that transformation
and we work provides an important tool
ideas have a place in the mind of their
creators but they need a place a space
to become innovations and those ideas
need to encounter other ideas and that
is exactly what we work provides we
works websites as we create environments
where individual pursuit and
collaboration collide I love that
expression the space is important not
only as a location but as an inspiration
and this is truly an inspiring space as
one might expect since it was designed
by a real architect we have an
organization at Columbia called the
Columbia organization of rising
entrepreneurs one of the largest
organizations on campus it has almost
2,000 undergraduates associated with it
in one way or another it aims to educate
inspire and launch educate people
students about being entrepreneurs
inspire them to propel that interest and
help them launch endeavors it has lots
of programs start the startup internship
program we have with the Center for
Career Education the core product
challenge in which students can learn
about the product development cycle the
core town hall which has alumni
presentation and student pitches of
their ideas and startup Columbia
challenge a competition for funding if
you go to the core website you can read
a part called seniors who build where
seniors in columbia college and school
of engineering and applied science in
general studies talk about themselves
and their
devers and I will quote two of them to
you today Don you Columbia College 2014
wrote working at a start-up is like
traveling with a band and what we have
it we work is a band in just behind me
it just isn't traveling right now Sarah
Chang Columbia College 2014 wrote no
means just not now and try again later
and this space is an opportunity to try
and try again until you are successful
this is an important space not only to
our students in the university but it's
also an important space to New York City
and it is an element in historic
preservation now we don't think of
entrepreneurship as being connected with
historic preservation but it really is
because New York itself has for
centuries been a center of innovation
and this neighborhood in particular just
down the street at 85 Eric in 1853 young
man named Heinrich engelhard Steinbeck
started a company but later changed his
name to Steinway and became the iconic
brand for pianos this area was once
called the printing district it was the
home to more than a thousand printers at
a time when New York was decidedly the
center of that industry if we had used
the phrase like Silicon Alley that we
use now if we'd use that phrase in the
nineteenth and early twentieth centuries
this would have been called cellulose
alley because of all the printers change
is inevitable but New York is about
change it's about innovation it's about
new ideas it's about development
Columbia and New York City and this
location we work are all about that
today we have at we work columbia alumni
who columbia college alumni who are
working on improving healthcare
promoting raw denim selling luxury knit
we're supporting maternal nutrition
providing online business strategies and
turning action sports into social
experience many of these will become
extremely successful
business is in the future and those who
are propelling them if those businesses
aren't successful will recognize that no
means just not now and you can try again
later schumpeter was a great economist
I'm not but I have a way of expressing
this in my own way and that is what can
be conceived can be created Columbia
entrepreneurship and we work are all
about that and this space and its
location are one of the reasons i can
continue to say that columbia college is
the greatest college in the greatest
university and the greatest city in the
world and all of that is in evidence
today and I'm very happy to be here
participating in that and now I'd like
to turn this back over to the leading
entrepreneurial force behind Columbia
entrepreneurship Richard witness
I'm just an MC thank you Jim and thank
you Mary and thank you glenn and thank
you lee for your thoughtful and
incredibly insightful comments it's now
my pleasure to introduce Eric Gertler
the executive vice president of the New
York City Economic Development
Corporation who is representing Mayor
Bill de Blasio thank you Richard and on
behalf of the mayor deputy mayor Glenn
and Carl Kimball the president of the
EDC it is my pleasure to congratulate
President Lee Bollinger Richard Witten
and all of Columbia for opening up this
new startup space here in i guess the
printing district so at the EDC we are
focused on number different things but
certainly we're focused on quality job
growth making sure that we're creating
opportunity for all New Yorkers and also
ensuring that we're creating
diversification throughout all five
boroughs but also in in all industries
we all know that the tech ecosystem has
grown in New York City it now employs
almost 300,000 New Yorkers and the great
thing is that its continued to grow it's
been growing at a pace about eight
percent per year which is which is great
for New York and it's great to see
additions like this just continuing to
add to the ecosystem and adding to the
vibrancy of New York City so I
congratulate Columbia for opening this
space but we also know it's all about
the entrepreneurs one of the companies
is a company called sin Ville which
actually was a winner in a competition
that Columbia in the city hosted a
number of months ago it's actually
ironically we're in a printing area here
but it's a 3d printing company so once
again showing the innovation and we just
have modest expectations for all the
entrepreneurs here in this base we're
just looking for you know billion-dollar
companies and employ lots of new yorkers
from all five boroughs so again
congratulations
thank you Eric about nine months ago my
colleagues and I met with we work
co-founder Miguel McKelvey because we
believe we work was an important member
of the Manhattan startup ecosystem
following our meeting with Miguel almost
as an afterthought he showed us this
space which was vacant and frankly a
dump at the time on that day this space
was a very dusty stack of cinder block
and dust and we can't thank him and his
team enough for their partnership
leadership creativity as they
transformed this space into what we see
here now Miguel's business we work is
now 19 places like this in how many
different countries 66 cities and with
with global aspirations i believe so i'd
like to introduce miguel mckelvey and
ask them to say a few words
Richard already stole my story a little
bit because one of the things I wanted
to say when when this conversation
started nine months ago it really was
just a conversation around a table it
was an entrepreneurial conversation
about big ideas of things that could
possibly happen and to be honest I left
that conversation like I leave a lot of
conversations like wow some cool ideas
were discussed but you know this is a
big institutional University chances are
not much is going to happen there's
probably like three years of bureaucracy
ahead of me and you know someday we'll
be having discussions about some other
building in the future but I can't
imagine what happened after that from
Chris and David and Richard the amount
of effort that they put in in pushing
this thing forward was extraordinary and
I really was surprised that the way that
the University and the rest of the deans
from what i heard responded to the ideas
that they presented it really was a
shock to me that we were able to make it
happen I do you think it's a really
unique partnership it's something that
we see ourselves as really a start-up on
the edge of development we're trying to
do a lot of things that haven't been
done before and that's not normally the
kind of thing that that's not usually
something that ties together well with a
large institution and so for us to come
together in this space which again I'll
echo Richards we're sitting now was
literally where all the trash from
subway and Dunkin Donuts was parted out
every day so it took an extraordinary
amount of imagination for them to be
like
I was like yeah we have this terrible
almost basement over here which we can
transform for you again it took
imagination on their part and so I
really congratulate them and
congratulate all you guys who tore this
location we're able to foresee something
that could become what it is we're
extraordinarily excited this is the
first partnership we've ever done like
this it's really for us something we see
as a model but in to connect an
institution like Columbia to what we're
doing is really extraordinary it's a
great validation of what we're trying to
accomplish we call ourselves a community
of creators we think that we're helping
people get through that difficult time
that challenge when you're at the moment
of creating something new and trying to
bring it to life and the more we support
we can have for that across the board is
a great thing for all of us and a great
thing for the world so thank you to
everyone who continues to support us
thank you to columbia extraordinary
thing for you guys to be a part of this
and we look forward to a great future
together thanks
so almost done I'd like to invite new
york state senator Bradwell meant to say
a few words thank you for that generous
introduction almost done that's that
that note I i am i'm very honored to
welcome you to the neighborhood as was
noted this is a historic district with
printing and piano manufacturers and and
and manufacturing and we're very glad I
know I speak for my colleague
Assemblymember Glick that manufacturing
is returning here to hudson square
there's a lot of vibrancy occurring in
the neighborhood a lot of great
restaurants which i'm sure your
entrepreneurs have discovered or will
discovered a soon i think it's worth
mentioning again the explosion in
technology in the new york city economy
and how important it is to the vibrancy
and future of our city and state since
2007 500 digital startups have begun in
new york and that's a credit to the work
the mayor's team is doing every day a
seventy-four percent increase in
technology employees a twenty-eight
percent increase in IT jobs six million
square feet of space and we can add 50
100 square feet today to that number and
according to the Center for in urban
future 28 new york-based startups were
founded holds your seat by Harvard
Business School graduates so we want to
increase that number and make sure
Center for an urban future starts
recording how many Columbia startups
have have occurred here and and again
congratulations to we work I have before
now I have four locations in my district
including Soho the Empire State Building
Meatpacking District and bryant park so
thank you for being such good neighbors
and bringing such interesting folks
you two to my district and to the
entrepreneurs you're doing a terrific
job the breath is quite extraordinary
clothing personal services food there's
even an app where private boat owners
are being connected to license captains
kind of like uber mates sailboats I
guess but congratulations on all your
work it's a it's a real honor a
testament to the vision of Columbia
welcome to the neighborhood look forward
to continuing to work with you thank you
so much
so having removed my foot from my mouth
I'd like to introduce now New York State
Assembly Member Deborah Glick since it's
just me between the ribbon cutting I'll
be brief sometimes I say I'll not only
be short but I'll be brief but I also
want to acknowledge that we have a
representative here from Congress member
nebulas office so I think that that
shows how important this innovation in
using this space is a Miguel your
explanation made it sound like a cross
between house hunters and
propertybrothers so I think that this is
a very exciting day for those of us who
struggle in government to see how we can
move forward possibilities for young
people to find themselves and to start
off in new directions and I chair the
committee on high red and I know that we
have great universities all over the
state but we are very pleased to have
this particular great University come to
the district and we really are pleased
that they've made this commitment to
their alumni that's very important and
if you are successful you will get many
direct mail communications from the
University
but this is about helping you not just
get a great education and be inspired to
do more it is giving you a place where
you can find your way in the world and
it's exciting for you it's exciting for
the neighborhood it's exciting for New
York so I congratulate all of you who
had the vision to support these
youngsters and to me you are youngsters
um but also I'm so pleased that you have
chosen to make New York the place that
you want to make your way in and where
you want to be successful and where you
want to bring innovation so we're
pleased that you're here and that you
didn't go to California thank you